have a look at the start of it now if
you have a look at what this diner is
about this is like a year worth of rain
recorded in the city by the way just a
quick question rhetorical question I
hope so you know the answer but maybe
some you've never gone down for rain is
like it's a volume right like you have
you can put rain into a cop or a
container not going to do why is it in
an answer if you know it's just
interesting why is it the rain is
measured in millimeters who decided that
why is it millimeters and not say
millimeters cube that's on volumes about
anyway just an interesting question for
your ponder what you have a look at this
done okay we've looked at bar charts and
we've hunted wine graphs this morning
out of those too if you had to choose
one of those which would be a bad choice
do you think for this particular that
mine I probably go with the line graph
why might that be the choices that we
make the trend yeah good there's this
you got both factors in your favor right
number one you're like oh I've got some
more rainy months and some less rainy
months and obviously like four months
but what's the comparison and secondly
this is this is just chronological data
right so maybe I want to work out what's
happening like halfway between evil and
met and I can work out that trend so
great a line graph makes sense but I
want to go a little further on that you
might recall I gave you that on Monday
to Friday share price that was going up
and down to like 50 this is january to
december right so you have a whole year
and presumably in most places something
like rain is seasonal yeah like you get
the more in this case interesting i
associate spring with rain which looks
like we're in a weird place or maybe
this is like Norman history anyway
you've got rain that cause of particular
times in the year and you got drive
here's a particular plans in the year so
it makes sense it after here you just
whip right back down to january and
you'd expect a very similar pattern okay
so being that Riley starting from one
point and ending in another your
endpoint is kind of like where you
started right december to january we
represent our line in a circular form
okay
now it's called a ray diagram maybe you
want to write this down as you're
heading it's called a [ __ ] manner
because in aircrafts and other people
who use radar right you're in the center
and you send out like this radial pulse
and then it bounces back to you so
here's you in the middle and you get
something that looks like this which
tells you how far away is stuff so this
is kind of what a radar display looks
like so that's what its name after okay
now you don't need to draw this bit but
when we're doing a line graph you sort
of do a vertical axis and a horizontal
axis and then off you go putting in your
data and all that come from ok now the
horizontal axis and the vertical axis
are both here but they oriented very
differently obviously the most important
part is right there the middle ok this
is our origin so this is like this spot
over here ok this is like rainfall zero
and time zero so january ok on here i'm
going to ask you in a minute when you
represent this to put on our vertical
line here this vertical line represents
our vertical axis that we would normally
have ok they're poison me again think
back if you were drawing a line graph
what do you think would be a suitable
step a suitable increment to go up each
time 2 2 4 6 8 10 I'm going to go a bit
better than that I reckon 10 or 20 would
be fine ok 10 or 20 now you can see it's
pretty easy if I say wanted to do 10 I'm
gonna have to go up to 80 yeah so I'm
going to go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and there
will be my turn into a corner on here
it's pretty easy to make lots of extra
markings but on a raid autograph it's
actually quite hard to draw you guys can
you're welcome to burn compasses free
meal
it will make it considerably easier
probably trying to free hit it as I in
generally speaking as you can see it
gets pretty busy pretty fast I'm going
to go with someone suggested 20 okay so
here on my vertical scale this will be 0
in the middle then 20 40 60 and 80 okay
now instead of just going from left to
right as my normal line graph does right
I am going to be going round the circle
so this first line here this is January
right this is my start point so I'm
going to look on their site wide Rainier
is 68 degrees something like something
like that it's been hot it's less than
halfway between 60-80 and then I'm gonna
have to go all the way around the circle
with an extra line for each one of my
months okay so here goes februari I'm
just thinking out I haven't actually
measured this out think about it um
think back to your sector graph thing
right how many gaps am I going to need
to have between all of mine why it's
going up there cool radio say again yeah
so I've got 12 right so a clock starts
at 12 and then it goes 1 2005 zone 8 9
10 11 here so therefore I guess I have
january-february i'm going to have one
two and then three would be over here
right so you can see i can complete
these all up and eventually i won't
complete it right now i'm going to get
all of these things together etc all the
way around each time it's kind of like a
new axis but because they're not
vertical anymore they're not vertical
internet because they're going along a
radius of the circle we call these
radial axes so that's probably worth
writing down
as well okay and I have a different
radial access for each one of the months
that I've got what days or whatever kind
of thing is on my vertical act in the
same way I'm going to keep on bettering
so let's see 74 that's going to be a bit
above halfway 55 ways that's going to be
that there's 50 there so 55 something
like that the last one I've drawn is
equal we've got 50 bang on so that's
halfway okay so you can see I'm gonna
have to complete this all the way around
just like with my line graph I'm going
to connect the dots right so I'm gonna
have some way yes yes okay so this looks
like a spider especially when if you
recall a couple exercises ago when you
did stem-and-leaf plots right a
stem-and-leaf plot starts with the stem
and leaves go this way okay but if
you've got like two groups of data like
take two teams or two classes you
sometimes have the stem of it all leaves
going this way and you know like an
actual plant leaves going the other way
as well because you're comparing the two
I could do the same thing here I could
have the rainfall in one part of the
world and then I could have rainfall in
another pot of water and I'm just doing
comparison so I could have another line
snaking its way around so this is where
my radar graph looks like i finished the
example i've given you